مخطوف و نحن نعرف اننا هجمنا مناطق قريبه
من وجود المنطقه التي كان فيها وى جانب
معلومات تتوفر لدينا مع ذلك انا اطلب ان
ابلغكم انه في الايام الاخيره التقى ممثل
جيش الدفاع مع ممثلي عائلات ي واعربوا عن
خشيتهم من حياتهم بعد معلومات
وص
الصعبه نحن نتواصل مع العائلات ونبلغ
بالتفاصيل المعروفه لدينا عن اعزا وسنواصل
تبليغكم تبليغهم بكل معلومه تصل الينا
وبعد ذلك نبلغ الجمهور حماس يستغل الحقيقه
ان المجتمع الاسرائيلي يقدس حياه حياه
مواطنيه نعم المجتمع الاسرائيلي يقدس
الحياه في داخل المجتمع هذه قوت
تعاو والخوف نحن نعمل بكل الوسائل من اجل
اعادتهم الى الوطن ومن اجل ان هذه بوصلتنا
وهذا طريقنا وادعو الجمهور ان يمتنع عن
نشر الشائعات والمعلومات غير الدقيقه
ويستمع الى
توجيهاتنا دفاعي افغان قال الليله ان
الضغط العسكري فقط هو سيعيد المخطوفين
وا سيبقون في الاسر سنوات
طويله
ايضا كيف ذلك الامر يتماشى مع ما يجري في
خونس وهناك لدينا هدف وهذا ياخذ وقتا وهي
عمليه مركبه تحدث تحت الارض وايضا لديها
المسيره الخاصه بها وايضا هناك الكثير من
القوات قوات خاصه وهذه معالجه في ايدان
قتال لا جيش في العالم موجود في مثل هذه
الظروف نحارب من تحت الارض وايضا نعمل
بالطريقه المناسبه من اجل ان لا نضر بال
المخطوفين ومن اجل ان ان لا تصاب قوتنا
وهذا ياخذ وقتا ونحن نحتاج الى هذا الوقت
ثاني ونصف ولكن علينا ان نصل الى هناك
ونحقق هدفنا تحدثت عن الضغط العسكري يجب
علينا ان نعمل كل ما نستطيع ونبد كل ما
نستطيع من اجل اعاده المخطوفات والمخطوفين
ايضا من خلال عمليات استخباريه وايضا
بالماضي وصلنا الى الى اتفاق لاعاده
المخطوفين من خلال توقف النار سنعمل كل ما
يمكن بكل الطرق وجيش الدفاع وهذا الامر
منوط في مجلس الوزراء لز هذا هذا لم اقول
اريد ان اعود على ما قلته قلت نحن نواصل
العمل نبذل كل جهود لدينا قياده مع الون
التي تنظر الى كل الجهود ليس العسكريه فقط
وانما الجهود الاخرى لكننا نركز بالعمليات
العسكريه من تحت الارض وفوق الارض وهذا
ايضا قيمه ونعمل في خانيونس ما لا نرغب في
ان نذهب الا ان نحقق هذه المهمه وايضا
مهمتنا ان نحقق الظروف التي تمكن اعاده
المخطوفين
ما موقف جيش الدفاع فيما يتعلق بالخلاف في
مجلس الوزراء حول تحرير المخطوفين
لا شك ان اعاده المخطوفين هي مهمه وطنيه
عليا وتركز هنا على كل هدف نسعى اليه
وتفكيك حماس احد اهداف الحرب ون ن نواصل
العمل ونفك ونفك في شمال قطاع غزه وفي
معسكرات الوسطى وفي منطقه خان يونس هناك
مناطق اخرى يجب مواصله العمل حسب البرنامج
هناك امور معقده وايضا في نهايه الامر نحن
نعرف هذا الترتيب والتعقيد في الامور
لدينا كل يوم تقييمات للاوضاع من اجل ان
نقرر كيف نفعل وهناك نحول امور الى مجلس
الوزراء ليتخذ فيها قرار
نحن نصل بطريقه منظمه ونعرض هذه المشاكل
وايضا نعرضها على طاوله
وهذه سيتم مناقشه هذه الامور مع كل
الامكانيات ونعرض ذلك على مجلس الوزراء